on the 22nd of may 2017 the threat level
set by the joint terrorism analysis
center was severe
that meant that a terrorist attack was
highly likely
whilst a threat was not specific to any
particular premises
the arena was always a possible target
for terrorists
there had been previous attacks in paris
and bavaria
which had shown that popular music
events such as these those held at the
arena
could be a target
everybody concerned with security at the
arena
should have been doing their job in the
knowledge that a terrorist attack
might occur on that night
they weren't no one believed it could
happen to them
the threat level had been that severe
for a period in excess of two and a half
years
and it is difficult to maintain a level
of preparedness over a long period
that is not a criticism of the threat
level
while the threat was high the level
needed to be at severe
it was the responsibility of managers to
ensure
that the message that the threat level
was severe was refreshed in such a way
that people did not become complacent
about it
the essential message is that all
employees
need to be on the lookout for suspicious
behavior
which when they see it they should
report to their relevant
supervisor employees must know
how to identify suspicious behavior be
encouraged to report it
and not feel that they may be criticized
if it turns out to be a false alarm
further there was insufficient sharing
of information between those people
concerned with security at the arena
another recurring theme in this enquiry
is the need to efficiently share
information with partners and neighbors
the effect of this will be to
greatly increase the efficacy of the
response
i will now briefly say something about
recommendations that i've made
in my report i have made a number of
recommendations which
if accepted will i hope bring about
changes which will make a further attack
less likely
central to my recommendations has been
consideration
of a protect duty the idea of a protect
duty has been around for some time
but it has been given new impetus by the
hard work of figan murray
whose son was one of the victims of this
outrage
a government consultation is ongoing and
people need to understand
how important a protect duty will be if
introduced
and the wide range of people who will be
affected by the proposal
i would encourage people to participate
in the consultation if they have not
already done so
there is limited time to respond the
consultation ends on the 2nd of july of
this year
i have concentrated on considering a
protect duty for large premises
such as the arena i fully
support the entire introduction of such
a duty
i have not dealt with the other
categories of a protect duty proposed by
the government
because i have not heard evidence
relating to them and very different
issues arise
in relation to premises like the arena
i have recommended that the requirements
of the duty are stringent
there seems to me to be no reason why
large commercial organizations should
not take
all reasonable precautions to protect
their customers
from a terrorist attack
there will be different views as to how
stringent the duty should be
and ultimately it is for parliament
representing the public
to decide the appropriate proportionate
level
having heard about the effect of the
deaths of the 22
people who died on their families and
friends
and the effect on those left permanently
injured
i consider that a rigorous duty is
appropriate
i hope that the consultation will lead
to a lively debate
on what is an important matter and that
it will be possible
for it to be passed into law quickly